talking of policing I wonder if we could
move on to other issues in the news at
the fact that the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak has been issued a fixed penalty
noticed by Lancashire police for not
wearing a seat belt in a moving car it's
the second time he's had a fixed penalty
notice from police and he's only the
second serving prime minister after
Boris Johnson to be fined by police
while in the position so should he
consider his position
no I don't think so if you look at the
context of it or indeed the context of
the earlier fine which was I mean very
much for inadvertent Behavior but look
the Prime Minister has been very clear
so it's a mistake he's put his hand up
people want that kind of honesty he's
apologized he'll pay the fine it was an
inadvertent mistake and it shouldn't
have happened and he's been very clear
about that so it's just a secretary it
doesn't worry you that the Prime
Minister has broken the law again
look of course it shouldn't have
happened
um but I I think with these things what
people expect most of all is uh you know
the individual concern whoever it may be
but the hand up be honest about it
accept the mistake pay the fine and I
think look given the uh the
circumstances
um I I don't think it's something which
would result in his resignation and
actually what he's doing uh as he's
shown this week is getting on with the
job on the economy we've seen inflation
coming down the leveling up agenda to
broaden the opportunity for young people
and uh for people in the most uh the
toughest backgrounds in our society in
our country and I think that's what
people expect
labor is saying that he looks like a
laughing stock and this is the prime
minister who did stand on the steps of
Downing Street when he took the job and
promised professionalism didn't he he
also does need trust at a time of some
of those challenges that you talked
about that the cost of living crisis for
example so does this just all make him
look a bit unserious and a bit foolish
look I think you've got someone doing a
very busy job as many people do so it's
no excuse who's made an inadvertent
mistake he's put his hand up he's
apologized for it but I think what your
viewers will want to know most of all
you talked about the cost of living
challenge is is getting on with a job
that's serving their priorities and if
you look at some of the upgraded
economic forecasts for example the
November GDP growth if you look at the
inflation figures coming down if you
look at the for example the investment
to this country recent PWC uh survey
showing third top in the world the CEO
is looking where to invest I think it
shows that he's got the right plan that
it's working look he's made a mistake
he's put his hand up but actually he's
absolutely committed to serving the
people of this country and getting us
through this difficult economic time
okay so has this gone too far no I think
um It's Perfectly proper wouldn't we we
wouldn't second guess the the role of
the police in this
I want to move on to ask you about your
colleague at Nadine zahawi the
conservative party chair now because
he's facing questions about his tax
Affairs it's been reported this week
that he's had to pay millions to hmrc to
settle a dispute the guardian is now
alleging that uh that money included a
penalty as well are you able to shed any
light on this for us are these reports
true
well look I can't speak for the personal
tax Affairs of a colleague but what I
would say is that Nadeem has been very
clear uh that he's paid all the tax that
he's owed uh that he's paid it on time
that there's nothing outstanding due
um and I think that's of course right
and proper
but do you accept that it's important to
establish that
on this because as I understand it
penalties are paid up when someone
doesn't pay the correct
tax at the right time aren't they so
that would be pretty serious as a former
Chancellor wouldn't it and there's a
conservative party chairman we need
transparency don't we well I think he
has been very clear on this uh you're
speculating on whether or not for
example as being no I understand I don't
know I'm not responsible for his
personal tax Affairs I'm sure you can
ask him that question all I'm saying is
that my understanding he's been very
clear on this is that he's paid all the
tax he was owed and there is nothing
outstanding due but if there's any
further questions I'm sure those are for
Nadine I I don't know their personal tax
Affairs but but are you completely
confident that Nadine sahawi has been
completely honest and open about his tax
Affairs yes that's the I think he has
been in the way I've described he's done
a great job as a government Minister you
think particularly with the vaccine
rollout he's done a whole range of jobs
in government but most obviously I think
people will recognize the role that he
played and the fastest vaccine rollout
uh in Europe and internationally
um and he's hugely committed to serving
the people of this country of course his
tax Affairs are a legitimate point of
scrutiny he's been very clear and I can
only tell you what he said and he's been
very upfront that he's paid all the tax
that was outstanding will he still be in
this post in a month's time
with the months a long time in politics
I certainly hope so
no more confidence
than let's hope he will be well look um
I'm confident he's done a great job in
government uh and and uh as I said he's
a colleague he's a friend of mine
um and he's as far as I understand and
he's been very clear on this he's paid
all his tax and there's there's no tax
due I mean I think that's the critical
uh point in this but if there's further
questions of course I'm sure um there'll
be the proper transparency I just don't
know I'm not responsible for any of my
colleagues personal tax affairs